[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday August
9th and you're gonna have to eat a
blenderize - happy meal 189 that's not
technically enough except that like 50
people give money the foundation to
decrease worldsuck so they can see you
eat that blender ice happy meal
nerdfighters so it looks like we're not
gonna get any further than we already
are
John I'm gonna call it you have to eat a
blender eyes tap email this begs the
question what kind of Happy Meal and
what kind of drink you will have to get
will it be you know one of the many soda
flavors or will we have to go the
healthy route and have you blend it with
milk these are things that I'm pretty
much I'm just gonna leave up to you I
really I don't think I'm gonna watch
that I would almost rather see a peeps
except I know how much they induce
nausea Oh anyway I'm glad that Daniel
Biss and the entire world is going to
benefit from your pain and discomfort
I'll just talk about the local election
in Chicago has kind of gotten me
thinking about the national election
that's coming up and I'm scared I'm
scared and I don't know who to vote for
we're supposed to be Obama guys we're
Obama guys it's just debts forgiven but
I don't know there's a lot of candidates
and there's a lot to know and there's a
there's a lot that we're gonna know more
about in the future I think today I'm
gonna start my presidential candidate
research and I'm gonna do it with your
book an abundance of katherines in mind
now what do I mean by that I'm gonna try
and figure out who to vote for by Anna
gramming the names of the presidential
candidates let's start with my favorite
candidate Albert Gore now he's not
running which is why it's probably true
an Al Gore announcing his presidential
candidacy now makes about as much sense
as a retro bagel so it kind of comes
down to the big three then doesn't it at
Hillary Brock and John Edwards I'm kind
of a John Edwards fan myself especially
because it's obvious he's gonna be hard
on terror as John Edwards anagrams to
jihad drowns but I'm still willing to
give Hillary a try until I realized that
Hillary Clinton anagrams to lynch a
trillion yes she is an advocate of
population control Hillary Rodham
Clinton anagrams to China a mild horny
troll I'm not sure
this is in reference to her opinion of
the Chinese or to her a policy toward
China in any case I don't know that I
technically agree and now we're left
with your men Barack Obama which
anagrams poorly Barack Obama anagrams to
maracas kebab but if you put in the
middle name
middle names can be important Barack
Hussein Obama you get Bush maniac Cobra
sake which in general it sounds kind of
cool
hopefully the Cobra will take care of
the bush mania and then we'll all toast
with little Gus is a sucky Japanese rice
wine now I know what you're thinking
I've left out other Republicans so here
they are Ron Paul anagrams to lunar up
as in lunar operations so I guess he'll
be taking this to the moon
Mitt Romney anagrams both to metro minty
so I guess we can count on him for gay
rights but also anagrams to are not my
time which is the hall cat way of saying
maybe in 2012 but much more frightening
than that is Rudy Giuliani which
anagrams directly to gaudily I ruined
also for his full name Rudolf Lewis
Giuliani you get i pious liar I'll undo
hug don't like it when people undo hugs
you can't undo hugs and finally possibly
my favorite poor Joe Biden I need job
and that's all we have for Hank Green's
and a grabbing guide to the 2008
presidential elections thank you John I
will see you tomorrow
oh I almost forgot so the nerdfighters
have been working on a brotherhood 2.0
wiki and we've just moved it on to the
Brotherhood 2.0 site to officialize it
it's at wikidot Brotherhood to calm and
you can add to it anybody can add to it
and we can edit it add anything it's
based upon the wikimedia platform just
like wikipedia and now i'm gonna go by